les rues de melbourne pratiquement
désertes face à une flambée de cas de
kobe de 19 avec plus d'une centaine de
nouvelles infections quotidienne les
cinq millions d'habitants de la seconde
ville australienne ont dû se
reconfigurer pour une durée de six
semaines
sortie autorisée uniquement pour raisons
professionnelles pour faire de
l'exercice physique ou acheter des
produits de première nécessité les
habitants se prépare à revivre une
période particulière ce n'est pas une
épreuve
nous sommes libres vraiment
fondamentalement libre on peut toujours
faire ce qu'on veut dans les
appartements nous pouvons toujours nous
promener et profiter du soleil
j'ai l'impression que nous faisons du
bon travail dans l'ensemble aussi
frustrant que ça peut être je le
soutiens mais redemander le mois dans
six semaines
j'étais un peu stressé à l'idée d'y
retourner et je ne comprends pas
pourquoi les chiffres sont maintenant
beaucoup plus élevé qu'il ya trois mois
je suis juste déconcerté
la durée de ce reconfirme ans pourrait
être réduite en fonction de l'évolution
de l'épidémie dans le pays qui
comptabilise actuellement près de 9000
cas de kobe 19